it's monday which i guess is scream day
monday scream day you like that came
over there myself
all these days all gotta have a name now
in any case reviewing the scream movies
on monday
that seems like a good idea so let's let
the saga of the halloween movie review
extravaganza continue
scream too that's right contacts are
back which means my true form is
revealed
no werewolf hands though does all
werewolf hands look like
complete ass in terms of costume i mean
my werewolf hands aren't impressive so i
have these human hands
uh hiding my true form enjoy the
eyeballs though they hurt like hell so
scream two is the second film in the
scream saga came out a mere
year after scream one and i'm gonna be
completely honest with you when i first
saw scream my friends and i
remember we stood outside we were those
kids we couldn't get a ticket we were
too young so we stood outside and
coached some
person we gave him money and said hey
can you just say you're our uncle so he
bought us the tickets thanks man his
name was tim i remember these things
thank you tim
anyhow we were those kids saw scream too
and not gonna lie
i was disappointed by scream too i just
saw it as a case of a sequel that's not
as good as the first movie it
disappointed me but given time
i've grown to appreciate scream 2 more
it's still a sequel it's not as good as
the first movie but you're comparing it
to the original screen the original
scream
was a game changer for the slasher flick
quintessential fundamental
important 90s slasher flick the original
scream so we're gonna talk about the
things i enjoyed about scream twos
things that disappointed me about scream
two and things that i grew to actually
appreciate and enjoy
over time about scream too in fact this
is gonna be a spoiler review so spoiler
alert right here in terms of talking
about the things that disappointed me
when i saw it
and the things i learned to appreciate
i'm gonna talk about
i'm gonna talk about who the killers are
in scream too so scream two takes place
on college campus that's right it scream
goes to college which a college campus
is a ripe
playground for a slasher killer not the
first movie to do it not by a long shot
but still
makes sense for the sequel to scream and
scream 2 sets itself up to continue the
playful nature of scream 1. you know
who's the killer who's doing it and
scream 2 was when we for the first time
see the film stab it's the movie within
the movie
that's movie allegory for slasher movies
yeah wes craven got really meta in the
90s it started with wes craven's new
nightmare and just carried us through
scream three the funny thing about that
is when you're seeing stab
you see clips and scenes and you know
the scenes that they are but they are
different
they're inaccurate which again take that
to heart for any movie that's based off
of a true story that's just how that
goes but also tori spelling plays sydney
prescott which is just hilarious in
screen one they were talking about oh
sid if they make a movie who's gonna
play you and she was like with my luck
they picked tory spelling and tori
spelling plays her
in stab the movie within the movie also
tori spelling did
audition for the role of sydney prescott
in the original screen which actually
makes that line
funnier because if tory spelling played
sydney in scream one and that line was
still in it again wes craven
loves his meta but one of the things i
liked about scream two again
nev campbell as sydney prescott sydney
prescott is truly a character who grows
she runs to a point
that first phone call like the actual
first real
screen ghost-faced killer phone call she
gets in the movie her answer is then
show your face you [ __ ] coward hangs
up the phone
granted he was right there and the chase
ensues but still
great answer you can just tell she's had
enough of it you see that at the very
beginning when someone prank calls her
he's like uh what's your favorite scary
movie and she's like who is this why
don't you tell me
she has caller id she's like all right
here's who it is and goes like oh [ __ ]
and he hangs up i feel like a lot of
other slasher movies would have the lead
star be like oh
it's happening it's starting again it
would like get in her head i've just
always loved the fact that sydney
prescott just doesn't have time for this
[ __ ] she's a character who
actually does grow through the [ __ ]
that's thrown at her and if we're
looking at the playful scream who
is it who's doing it who are the
suspects thing this movie does a good
job at keeping you guessing it's fun to
watch the characters here whether it be
mickey played by a younger timothy
olyphant
he's always recording things and he's
this film student he's just a complete
film fanatic is he filming things
because he's the killer or is he filming
things because you know he's a film
student leave schreiber plays
cottonweary which you saw a news clip of
him in the first scream
now he has been released his name has
been cleared but not fully cleared
people still treat him like wait a
minute you're the guy who killed the
yeah but you feel the desperation he's
so
desperate to clear his name that he kind
of comes across as obnoxious
which again you're like oh suspect even
tells gayle weather like gayle i did my
part and i'm like
does that mean you killed people sid has
a new boyfriend we saw how that went
down in the first screen
just the suspect list is a good suspect
list
and the guessing game that scream two
throws at you to keep you on your toes
does a good job with that ghostface
is still a klutz though i know i
mentioned that in my other review and
people are like
has it crossed your mind that is hard to
see out of the mask well
yeah probably i don't see a discernible
difference between what i'm like oh
that's billy loomis and that stew and
they're both clods but you gotta admit
that is funny other killers are like i'm
very efficient
dad ghost faces over here like fear me
rattle out [ __ ]
it's just funny to me just he's so
clumsy but if he wasn't clumsy you
wouldn't
have a movie because he'd just be so
easy at killing people like sydney
prescott would have been taken out in
two seconds and screamed one and i will
say this movie has great scenes great
scenarios great tension like that scene
with ghostface in the car where sydney
and her friend
they're in the car ghost faces in the
car ghost face is knocked out and they
have to crawl over him to get out
that's a great scene of tension granted
why weren't they just like all right
well
while we're crawling out here's his
knife i enjoy the fact that it's like
maybe he's unconscious maybe he's not
and we gotta crawl over this guy to get
out of here great moment attention also
david warner as the drama teacher
how can it be that david warner is so
good
that he can steal the movie at least for
this scene he's in and all he's really
doing is giving
a teacher to student pep talk he is in
fact so good
he was on my suspect list too i suspect
everybody in these movies i was like huh
drama teacher maybe he wants to make the
ultimate dramatic production
possible the point is whether he's the
voice of ray chalgool professor jordan
perry from secret of the use whether he
is the kardashian torturing picard the
two-parter chain of commands classic
he's just so good he
i just love the scene he's in i don't
believe you i don't
he's awesome then the film ends in the
drama stage which again i always found
funny it's just so perfectly timed and
perfectly planned you know sydney goes
there
because she can hear something going on
there they turned up all the volume on
the production sydney could have just as
easily been like it sounds like drama is
going on i need to get the [ __ ] out of
here though what if she didn't show up
there what if
she didn't follow the sound of the stage
production which probably had that sound
going on
many nights before it just cracks me up
visioning mrs loomis and mickey just
sitting there in their little
ghost face off it's like like i totally
thought she was gonna come here because
i don't know don't listen to me that
which brings me to the main thing more
or less when i watched scream two for
the first time i was like oh that's
disappointing is the killer reveal it
started from the fact that i
felt like this movie was just doing more
of the same from scream one i mean it's
really woven into the killer's
motivation as you see
people are being killed because they
have the same names as some of the
victims in scream one so i just felt
like the killer's motivation is to copy
the first movie
and this movie more or less feels like
well scream one crushed it so we'll just
do a scream too in randy and mickey's
film class they even talk about how
sequels are by definition inferior films
there's the whole debate of whether or
not
movies lead to violence which is funny
that's still
going on today and that was a big thing
back in the 90s i remember i thought
that argument was dead
and then joker came out in theaters and
i was like oh we're still having that
conversation we're still having that
screen 2 argument and nothing happened
but
you know i imagine in 20 more years
we'll have that argument again so
upon all that the ghostface killers are
revealed to be mickey
and mrs loomis or as i really saw them
upon reveal
the stew wannabe or the randy stew
hybrid and just the weird obnoxious
reporter lady pestering gail weathers
like a fan girl
she's the killer i'm just really
disappointed by it yes i know it's a
total throwback to mrs voorhees
i got that at the time too but i just
didn't appreciate it at the time it's
like you can have a throwback but
i just wanted to be more impressed with
the killers but
given time over the years i've actually
come to appreciate
this killer duo a lot more see
individually yeah sure maybe you'd be
disappointed but together
they do work and the movie completely
spells it out for you as to
what was going on why it was going on
apparently i didn't care at the time but
i actually really do appreciate it first
of all i should have picked mickey out
of the crowd
from the get-go it's like they were like
oh we want randy to be the killer
because a movie fanatic would be a
logical killer choice
in a slasher movie about slasher movies
but you can't do my boy randy dirty like
that
until you kill him in a van subjectively
i hated that randy died but first of all
it's actually really fun to go back and
re-watch the movie and see
things that mickey does and says there's
a lot of misdirection with mickey at
first glance and then when you rewatch
the movie you're like
no no it's just mickey being
manipulative the movie kind of wears it
on his sleeves like no
mickey's the killer and we're gonna kind
of make it obvious even the trailer for
scream too that has randy and dewey
going back and forth as to who the
suspects are he's like mickey the freaky
tarantino film student but if he's a
suspect so am i so let's move on or they
just they call the killer out in the
trailer because sometimes the best place
to hide is right out in front david
warner ninja turtles too secret of the
use he's incredible and mrs loomis wants
revenge for the death of her son i get
it i was like why would mrs loomis dress
up like ghostface but really if it was
just mrs loomis she wouldn't have
dressed up like ghost space
the whole ghostface schtick gimmick
thing was mickey so it's kind of awesome
to think about she talks to sydney how
finding an active serial killer is
actually a very rare thing so
mickey was a rare find you get the
feeling like mickey
was already a serial killer he had
already killed people don't know who
those victims are but the point is he
did so you get the feeling she was like
hey i need your help to get into college
and we're going to kill this girl and he
was probably like fine
oh [ __ ] sydney prescott like the whole
movie fanatic oh do i gotta make a
sequel so mrs loomis probably rolled
with it like
okay sure right let's dress up like
ghost face and [ __ ]
you just get the feeling that in order
to get mickey's help
mickey was like we gotta do the ghost
face thing so mrs loomis rolled with it
and went along with it so the lack of
originality
came from the mind of some movie fanatic
that mrs loomis
found to be her serial killer can you
kind of get at a point she was like dude
we're going after sydney now this [ __ ]
is let's just go you have enough victims
to play your whole like i'm going to
blame the movies thing who's probably
like yeah you're right so after that
the deaths that happened stopped being
because of their names and it was just
collateral damage
and mickey with his whole movie
motivation is a total out from mrs
loomis which she tries to use like all
right mickey blam
okay no one even knows about me so the
dynamic between
mrs loomis and mickey i actually grew to
appreciate it does feel kind of sloppy
but it's within context that it does
feel sloppy this lady made a deal with a
serial killer so she could
kill sydney prescott and this guy was
just he was just some movie freaked mind
who wanted to do a sequel and the whole
thing
just feels shoddy as much as i kind of
saw that for
scream two's execution it's actually
within the context of execution among
the two killer characters i grew to
actually enjoy that about this movie all
that is to say
in the end scream 2 started out as this
sequel that wasn't as good as the first
movie for me but in hindsight when you
look back and maybe it's because
i mean we live with our four screen
movies now if you look back
scream two is actually where they could
have ended it they could have just
ended it here and been like yeah scream
and scream too that's the whole saga
it actually would have been a pretty
airtight saga that's one of the many
reasons scream 2 has gotten better over
time with me in the end i'll say scream
too
it's a really good time no alcohol
required all right well before we get to
next monday where i
inevitably talk about screen 3. we got
some more horror movie reviews coming
this week in the horror movie
review extravaganza i might not do one
tomorrow on tuesday i might do monday
wednesday friday because there are a
couple of new movie releases coming this
weekend regardless that might be how
this week goes down but
again keep checking back more reviews
coming more horror more screams more
scarce
alright so scream two have you seen it
what did you think about it did it
disappoint you does it still disappoint
you have you grown to appreciate it
has it gotten better over time worse
over time what's your favorite scary
movie
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you